Melanie's with us in Wichita Kansas hi
Melanie how are you I'm good thanks for
taking my call sure what's up my husband
and I are in Week three of the SPU and
last night we sat down and we did the
allocated spending plan we had
everything set up for the month to where
every one of our dollars was assigned to
something well he had made a bet with
some buddies at work and he lost the bet
and this morning without saying anything
to me
he got paid today he took $200 out of
her account I don't even know how to
address this with him or even where to
get the money to get us back on through
track so what are your suggestions okay
so why did he not tell you about this
when you were putting the budget
together last night well we learned
about it and I told him you what about
it I knew about the beds okay but I told
him that if he wanted to pay the guy
back he needed to take it out of his
blow money not out of the rest of the
budget right and so how much was in his
blow money we do $18 a week okay well he
owes the guy $100 that was a dumb idea
you can't you can't give a guy $100 when
you only have 18 so you didn't have a
solution
well the gotten one $18 a month your
husband's word is on the line he owes
him a hundred bucks
so hundred bucks should have been in
your budget last night uh-huh so he did
address it he and I to you
you just didn't have a reasonable
solution and so he honored up and paid
his bill when it was due this morning so
$18.00 blow money's gone for sure that's
where that's 18 of it now we got to find
the other 82 and you guys got to wander
through the budget and do that tonight
so but so number one when you know
something's in front of you don't
pretend like it's not there
and that'll be helpful for the future
number two he has to understand that you
felt like you guys had a contract and
just like he felt like he gave that guy
his word he also gave you his word last
night and so now you feel like he kept
his word to that guy but lied to you and
he needs to feel that you had a contract
last night he broke the contract this
morning right well and he didn't feel
that he and you and that pissed you off
and I don't blame you okay
so you guys that that's the point when
we agree on something
on this paper it's a pinky swear in a
spit shake and we do not change it
without both of us coming back and
agreeing to change it and so what he
should have done when he left the table
last night he should have already had
the hundred dollars worked out and you
should have two in the budget so that
this so that the guy was paid what he
was owed the next day and don't make any
more stupid bets at work you're trying
to get out of debt now then that's what
y'all should have done but if that
didn't happen then when he got there
this morning and felt the pressure to
pay the bill that he owed to keep his
word he should have picked up the phone
and called you and said hey we got a
contract but I also got a contract over
here we got to work this out I'm not
okay with us doing this eighteen dollars
every paycheck or something I need to
pay this guy we need to work it out and
y'all talk it through on the phone and
adjust the contract does that make sense
uh-huh kind of if you get to the grocery
store and or you get to the gas station
and there's no gas and there's no gas in
the envelope you got to get home because
y'all screwed up your budget right then
you gotta call him and go I gotta get
home
so I'm taking a little bit out of our
food money because I got to get some gas
money in the car and we gotta adjust the
budget tonight and I wanted to tell you
ahead of time so you don't so you don't
feel like I broke my word to you when we
get home tonight because that budget
becomes a contract where you won't trust
each other that we're joining hands and
walking out of this and that's why
you're calling me because that made you
mad when he broke his word right
you know I don't blame you but but you
all set it up to where you put him in a
box and he didn't he's gonna break his
word to somebody this morning it was
just a matter of who and so and I don't
I don't like what he did but I also
don't like what y'all did last night
that put him in a box where he didn't
have choices so y'all if y'all too
handled it last night it wouldn't have
been there because he knew he was gonna
face this this morning when he got to
work he knew had to look at that guy and
go out with a guy on her bucks now I'm
not gonna Welch on the bet no you're not
gonna do that you're gonna pay your bill
and because that's what guys do when we
do stuff like this and that it may be to
Melanie that's a what I'm describing may
be a kind of a guy thing I don't know I
don't know if ladies act that way or not
but when two guys make a deal like that
it's like a blood oath you know and his
honor was on the line this morning is
where y'all put him you follow me I'm
not taking up for him because he he
dissed you in the process but you got to
understand he was under extreme guy
pressure honor his integrity was on the
line and that's why he did that he might
not have done it if it was something
else he might not have done it if he
just buy himself a candy bar or buying
himself something for $100 he might not
have done it but the good news is you
guys get to learn this real early in
your budgeting together process which
this is your first day doing it your
first week doing it and you get to have
a really good healthy discussion without
you yelling at him or something like
that but this is honey you don't
understand this is like you lied to me
that's how it feels and you're not a
liar and that's why I'm so upset this is
like a contract here we both initially
hey I'll tell you Melanie sharing I had
so many of those fights we killed each
other we got to where we had to initial
the corner of the budget like it was a
contract because we had we wanted to
make emotional have emotional surety
that we both understood how serious
sticking to our word was and I have been
on the phone standing in Sam's Club
going honey there's something on sale
here I'd like to get it's not like I'm a
wuss and I have to ask my wife
permission to go the bathroom or
something that's not the case
but I had made a promise to my wife
called a budget and I wasn't gonna break
my promise to my wife
so I call her and I go hey hey I'm gonna
be $10 over I'd like to take that out of
this other category is that cool she
says yes boom we have a budget we have
an amendment to the contract the
contract has now been amended and now we
buy the thing at Sam's Club and we come
home smiling and everybody's okay
but I did not just come home and go look
what I did which I used to do and that's
just as a stress right there so yeah
this is this is really tense day for you
it's been hard on him emotionally too
because he had to decide who he was
going to break his word to if he
understood that he gave his word last
night but you after tonight he'll
understand yeah if you explain it to him
clearly that this budget is a contract
between the two of you and when you
start treating it that way
man you guys are gonna do so good you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna call me
back on this change my marriage
this changed our communication level it
changed how we look at the future it
changed our view on everything it it's
amazing
marriage counselors use budged this very
budget technique to cause couples to
work together on life when they're
struggling at getting along because it
creates unity because when you agree on
your spending and you keep your word to
each other and you communicate heav'nly
you're agreeing on your life and so I
completely understand why you're upset
and I would be upset if I were in your
shoes too but understand you put him the
two of you his his not dealing with it
last night went beyond his part but the
two of you boxed him into a corner last
night and this morning he walked right
through the paint he painted in the
corner he walked his walk just took his
wet shoes right through the middle of it
and that that's what's happened here so
I'm really glad it's only a hundred
bucks and I'm really glad you knew about
it ahead of time sorta and I'm really
glad that you're ticked about it and you
guys are gonna have a good discussion
about it because it's really this is
gonna be a thing you point back to ten
years later and you go that was the day
that was the week we changed our life
right there so this is going to be great
as long as y'all talk it through and
come to solid agreement on this as a
contract
from this point forward very cool stuff
good call good call
that's normal stuff happening there this
is how you work through it this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]